it is certainly not simply the absence
of armed conflict peace is much broader
than that and I think that one of the
ways that discussion around peace the
possibility of sustainable peace is
stopped in its tracks is because peace
has been hijacked to seem this utopian
ideal and only you know idealists who
don't understand the difficulties of the
world want to work for peace you know in
its strumming a guitar and singing peace
songs and it's the beautiful vodka
eighties rainbow and the Dove flying
over it or under it no it isn't no it
isn't and when we allow those symbols to
stop discussion about what sustainable
peace is we you know we can ourselves
peace is not something that you know
tree-hugging liberals is one of the
things that we're called in the US or
utopians or granolas is another you know
because supposedly you know hippy peace
people eat granola and yogurt and wear
sandals and natural fibers you know
sustainable peace let me take you to the
Democratic Republic of Congo and you see
what the women are doing in those you
know in the eastern part of that country
trying to stop rape in conflict trying
to work with survivors of rape
that is not a rainbow and a dove it is
hard work every single day to try to
reshape our understanding of the world